nachdem ich bereits auf die erste folge
reagiert habe
hoffentlich gibts überblicken kann und
nachdem ich dann auch auf die zweite
folge reagiert habe erst mal war der
einfall haben wir heute meine damen und
herren endlich zum dritten teil von graz
klassenfahrt der presse auf den plan
jetzt sie macht schluss folge drei
kreisklassen fahrt unterstützt durch
produktplatzierung rein und spielt ja
ihr könnt ihr jetzt schon mal wetten
abschließen wie oft kennen hat heute
sein handy fallen lässt ganz kurz vor
euch die info was in der letzten folge
passiert ist und zwar ganz grob gesagt
alle haben sich irgendwie besoffen auf
einer party und die freundin von kenneth
also dem hier der so dummes und dem so
oft sein handy hinfällt seine freundin
ist von der party abgecheckt mit dem
stanley und die haben dann rum gemacht
das war dann das ende von der zweiten
folge kreisklasse fahren und jetzt
schauen die dritte reihe hat er ein
tampon der nase stecken die folge läuft
nicht mal eine minute und wir haben das
hier war über die nasenschleimhäute den
alkohol laufen da kann man so richtig
schnell hat er jetzt den tampon vorher
in wodka gelegt und sich in jetzt in die
nase gesteckt damit er schneller
besoffen jetzt frauen die da noch ein
tampon rein ins getränk und jetzt schaut
sich die
jetzt stecken die zwei sich dann von ihm
die nase ich was ist der große dieser
serie sorry aber älter und sie filmt es
natürlich auch italien hat jetzt ausland
an und dann trinken einfach ganz viel
alkohol ja also ich habe seinen namen
ehrlich gesagt vergessen wie gesagt
meine letzte was ja auch schon zwei drei
wochen her aber er sich anscheinend die
scham klären mal abwarten ob unsere zwei
tampon nasen heute noch was haben werden
der mann floh was machst du da immer nur
die bilder nur ganz kurze informationen
ist eine handy telefon radio schüler der
kenneth hier ist gerade rein geplatzt
wie er hier
der stanley was mit seiner freundin
hatte hat er kennt natürlich direkt
bilder von denen gemacht anstatt zu
fragen hey was geht ab
erst mal ein paar bilder machen dabei
ist ihnen sein handy hingefallen und was
ist natürlich das erste was er sagt wir
haben hier miteinander geschlafen
ganz kurz schöner blick erstmal kennen
aber erstmal frage ich mich hey warum
kommt die frau ostermann da jetzt an
und zweitens was versucht kenne damit zu
bewerten dass er frau ostermann sagt
dass seine freundin fremdgegangen ist
sie ist eine lehrerin sie ist keinen
aufpasser therapeut keine ahnung was
also ich bin gespannt wie das jetzt
ausgehen wir zwar boden auf
klassenfahrten müssten daher erlauben
[Musik]
okay okay sie hat zugegeben dass die
fremdgegangen ist dummheit zu
ehrlichkeit bewusst dass sein haus
geschickt
meine eltern sind nicht mal wach und die
wirft mich hier so einfach raus ich habe
nicht mal was gemacht das war zum glück
gar nicht abgelesen wird aber gespannt
was kommt jetzt wieder ganze situation
zu sagen hat kann das richtig fassen sie
muss die klassenfahrt jetzt schon
frühzeitig verlassen das ist alles meine
schuld ich hätte einfach nicht beim sex
unterbrechen dürfen
[Musik]
meine schuld ich hab so leben so richtig
bewusst denn du geile sau am rhein hat
uns gefehlt mit seinem handy und ich
habe noch zwei andere beziehungen
gleichzeitig
du läufst diese aufnahmen das will ich
einfach was der kollege allerdings wohl
leider nicht weit
wir können jetzt schon mal gehen und die
fragen ist es gerade dein ernst ist
derjenige der mich bei ihr verpfiffen
haben dir muss ich nach hause fahre hat
die jury nicht selbst zugegeben vor der
frau ostermann dass die fremdgegangen
ist also muss die joline nicht wegen dem
kennes nach hause fahren sondern wegen
ihr selbst mein handy
doch ich möchte nach hause und als du es
nicht bemerkt hast mit uns ist schluss
eigentlich keine überraschung
er soll das handy von kenneth kaputt
machen ich kenne einen taxifahrer
zufälligerweise ich könnte ihnen kurz
anrufen für dich wenn du mal
gut gute taktik er hat zwei lassen wie
jetzt die rider schild hölle
standgehalten
es ist kaputt wir haben kürzlich die
handys kann nicht kaputt gehen
ach so dank meiner einer schutzhülle
kann man handy keinen physischen schaden
nehmen
laut der legende ist ein handy hat eine
rheinische schutzhülle unzerstörbarer
als sein wie er auch lacht einfach was
geht da jetzt gerade plötzlich ab und
stieß in unserer klasse
nein nein wir sind nicht froh sein georg
putz nicht
[Musik]
also diese serie stellt jedes klischee
total überspitzt da aber ich glaube dass
auch so ein bisschen der sender rannte
der keller ist jetzt irgendwie auf
presse gegangen
er sitzt der halter wäschekorb ja das
duell weil das was soll das denn
gefahren das ist okay ich weiß auch
nicht was mich gefahren sei wenn ich
mich einfach in einem wäschekorb in dem
zimmer bitten wir sind im bad von wem
anders verstecken würde
die hülle ist von renault spielt meine
damen und herren falls ihr es noch nicht
mitbekommen hab das ist reine spielt das
ist seine höhlen marke das traurige ist
dass sich mittlerweile auch einfach
ungewollt für diese marke mache ich habe
jetzt begeben gesagt dass in die
kommentare schreiben soll wie oft
kenneth n die heute fallen gelassen wird
ich glaube wir sind gerade bei fünf oder
sechs aber wir haben ja noch vier
minuten bei diesem video jetzt eine
hülle geschenkt also dieses planes
mitnimmt einfach keine grenzen
leider russland ist auch das finde ich
ganz komisch frau ostermann die lehrerin
ist hart besoffen und georg trinkt
keinen alkohol und ist es ganz verdutzt
kann in meinem zimmer schlafen kann
sagen
ich finde es großartig wie frau
ostermann mich auch in schweren zeiten
unterstützt und ich bin sehr froh und
sehr dankbar dass ich diese nacht in
ihrem zimmer unterschlupf finden kann es
hat sich angehört wie vor einem
kriegsflüchtlinge jetzt läuft die
lehrerin mit ihren schülern gibt jetzt
wem genau jetzt weiter an die sache ist
dass hier interessiert mich gar nicht
sondern ich will eigentlich sehen was
mit frau ostermann und georg im bett
passieren wird sie kommt nach hause
die frau ostermann völlig betrunken auf
ihr handy und lässt sich fallen
ist die frage der fragen und die frage
ist auch ob sich nur ein schüler hat
[Musik]
was sind denn das für enden jedes mal
also hier sieht man jetzt was als
nächstes passieren wird
georg sagt da gerade den anderen beiden
dass frau ostermann ihn angefasst hat
sie hat gesagt dass sie noch jungfrau
ist kenne jetzt das ist sein handy das
ist kann aus drei metern auf den boden
geflogen was auch sonst wird nächste
folge mit kann es passieren dass kondome
seien für anastasia du bist in der
nächsten folge wird anscheinend ein
f filmchen gedreht also wenn ihr wollt
dass sich nächstes wochenende auf die
vierte folge von kratz klassenfahrt
reagieren soll dann lasst einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video hier da schreibt
mir und in die kommentare
wie oft in diesem folge das handy von
kenneth auf den boden gefallen ist
abonniert main kanal wenn ihr noch kein
teil der luxus seite und wenn ihr schon
abonnent sind dann klickt gerne auf die
glocke denn dann bekommt die
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen
[Musik]